Chỉnh quyền miên mà bởi vì đing áp dụng trẻ đo làm việc từ xa và 1 thử tư, đồ về các cơ quan nhà nước,
quyết định sẽ bắt đầu từ ngày 25 tháng 3 và kéo ra hàng tôn cho đến khi có thông bảo mối ý.
Theo thông báo đang trên báo nhà nước, The Mirror, mục tiêu trình của bệnh pháp là hàng trẻ dí truyền và sử dụng phương tệ khúc cản thiết.
Nhanh giảm tiêu thu như liệu trong buổi cảnh, một cùng trữ áp lực.
Cán bộ như sự của bật công, được yêu cầu không dí truyền, yêu công các bách trong ngày thử tư làm việc tanya.
Chỉnh phủ miên mà cũng kêu gọi các sân nghiệp và tổ chức tư nhân cần nhắc áp dụng một hình tương tự để gó phần tích kệ nắng lực.
Chức đoò miên mà đã chình khai nhiều bệnh pháp ứng phóng, mùi cơ thử như liệu,
nhiều luôn phía n sự giụ phương tiện theo biển số tránh lệ và phân lối hạn mức tự thủ.
Già săng tệ miên mà của thông báo tương đường khoảng báo em muốn nghiên, đến 3 mấy lâm nghiệp để nắm đồng một lý t'h theo nước nghiệp.
Sông tự tế thành những khu vực cao phân đáng kệ, miên mà hẹn tục đăng tìm các đa dạm khoảng 1, năng lượng để ruy trí ở liệu xấu trông thời gian tự ấy.